hi I'm silverette I make videos about
sandbox games but mostly roller coaster
tyon 3 since it's awesome I just like
designing buildings theme parks
Landscapes basically the stuff that
you're looking at right now aside from
straight up showcasing my work though I
make Let's Plays and tutorial videos and
sometimes random stuff because I
obviously get bored sometimes and yeah
it turns out that somehow people are
actually interested in what I make so if
you're interested too feel free to check
out some of my stuff now I'm not really
a big fan of telling people to subscribe
to me so I'll just end this video with
some random clipar
shot